qui va investir des milliards de dollars
pour fabriquer des vaccins
si une fois qu'il a trouvé un vaccin on
lui pique la réponse est personne donc à
la prochaine épidémie
nous n'aurons plus d'industriels du
vaccin et donc nous n'aurons plus de
vaccins nous n'aurons plus de protection
vaccinale
ça c'est le premier problème le deuxième
problème bien sûr c'est que d'imaginer
qu'on va piquer la propriété
industrielle de pfizer ou d'un autre
grand laboratoire et que les pays
concernés ne vont pas tiquer les brevets
de renault et de peugeot d'airbus
d'ariane c'est une naïveté absolument
extraordinaire il y aura immédiatement
des rétorsions puisque le droit de la
propriété intellectuelle est un droit de
réciprocité si je vous piquent vos
brevets vous allez faire la même chose
n'allait me piquer mes propres brevets
donc en réalité cela en faibliraient
considérablement l'industrie française
il manque je crois de furieuses donner à
mon contradicteur déjà lui rappeler que
pour les médicaments qui sont créées en
général elles fois il ya de la recherche
fondamentale qui est financé par les
fonds publics
si on prend le cas des états unis les
210 médicaments qui ont été qui sont
sortis entre 2010 et 2016 ont bénéficié
de plus de 100 milliards de dollars de
fonds publics
ça c'est une réalité et en heurtant
c'est la même chose il faut savoir que
en europe est un programme européen qui
les financent à hauteur de 3,3 milliards
sur 10 ans
les coopérations les partenariats
privilégiés avec les chiens donc nous on
est fiers ne se font pas tout seul et
hommes et pour prendre un exemple franco
français pour le couche de pâte et de
sanofi il faut savoir quand même que
c'est une entreprise publique à
l'origine je dois vous rappeler et vous
avez cité renouveau avait cité airbus
mais toi je vous rappeler aussi que ce
sont des entreprises qui est
qu'aujourd'hui ces entreprises qui ont
fait largement les profits des
investisseurs privés ils se sont appuyés
sur quoi mais sur un savoir faire
industriel qui issu d'une entreprise
publique dont qui est tulle pour public
c'est à dire qu'ils appartiennent aux
banques qui ont financé
c'est à nous de changer de logiciel
parce que tant qu'on change pas de
logiciel nous savons très bien que l'air
épidémie malheureusement ne sais comment
c'est parce que nous sommes face à un
changement climatique irrémédiable et
chypre et qu'elle ne nous serons
toujours impuissants si nous
reproduisons toujours les mêmes erreurs
[Musique]
mais l'idée que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques vivent dans une
forteresse en étant séparée du reste de
la société civile est un fantasme en
reste et l'industrie pharmaceutique
travail au coeur de la cité travail avec
les entreprises mais je n'ai pas de
conflit d'intérêt je ne sais pas
partition ce pas un lobbyiste au service
de l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais l'industrie pharmaceutique n'est
pas isolé en travaillant contre
l'intérêt de la population elle passe
son temps et son énergie à trouver de
nouvelles molécules et si aujourd'hui
80% des cancers de l'enfant sont guéris
par la chimiothérapie c'est grâce à
l'industrie pharmaceutique s'est passée
ta grâce à l'industrie betteravière ou à
l'industrie automobile
donc ce discours de la méchante
industries est un discours qui est
aujourd'hui dépassé l'industrie
travaille pour le bien-être collectif en
s'abritant des médicaments si comme vous
dites les gens les entreprises et la
boue pharmaceutiques se sont concernées
par l'intérêt général
pourquoi veut-il des postes de
chercheurs pourquoi fais tu me tires des
centres de recherche pourquoi puisqu'il
met dehors toutes ces personnes là si
vraiment c'est l'un des papes général
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on avait
quand même des tas comme avec le
chine et d'autres pourquoi pour non je
ne suis pas dupe je ne suis pas dans le
monde des bisounours
non je suis content très consciente des
choses qui se passent et aujourd'hui il
ya malheureusement un logiciel a changé
il ya une façon de faire qui n'est plus
acceptable et je ne suis plus d'accord
on ne sommes pas d'accord pour que les
brevets ce tour là que l'apanage
exclusif des entreprises privées alors
qu'elles ont bénéficié de financements
publics
ça me semble logique
[Musique]
l'afrique est très peu touchée par la
copie de 19
vous savez qu'il y à 200 fois plus de
chances de mourir de lakovic 19
quand on a plus de 60 ans que quand on a
moins de 40 ans donc dans les pays très
jeune comme blé pays d'afrique noire
francophone par exemple on a très très
peu de cas de kovy de grave
vous savez que au niger la médiane
d'agen là je mets 10 ans et 15 ans au
sénégal ses 19 ans donc on est face à
des populations très très jeune avec
très très très très peu de seniors et
donc on a très peu de morts en afrique
c'est un continent qui est extrêmement
peu de touches et donc l'urgence de
vacciner en afrique et notamment en
afrique subsaharienne n'est pas si
important que ça même si bien sûr il va
falloir vacciner tout le monde met donc
il faut pas confondre les pays du nord
où l'âge moyen est très élevé et où
lakovic 19 fait des ravages
et puis les pays du sud où l'âge moyen
est beaucoup plus jeune et il ya moins
de morts aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya
une minorité de pays
les pays riches qui s'accaparent ni
doses laissons de côté des millions de
personnes et c'est ça qui est
insupportable
aujourd'hui on a des états qui doivent
payer 2,5 fois plus cher que d'autres
pour pouvoir accéder aux vaccins non
c'est pas normal donc bien évidemment il
faut il faut changer il faut il faut
arrêter de dire on vous laisse ça aux
entreprises privées le soin de diffuser
et de produire les doses nécessaires
n'ont elles en sont aujourd'hui
incapables
donc il faut pour cela partagez les
brevets ou que les vaccins puissent être
produits par tous et que tout le monde
puisse avoir accès parce que tant que
malheureusement tant que tous les pays
n'auront pas accès aux traitements
eh bien ces pandas me monique nous n'en
sortirons jamais et comme je voulais dit
nous rentrons aujourd'hui dans l'ère des
pandémies
nous rentrons aujourd'hui fassent un
changement climatique qui va amener de
nombreuses crises aujourd'hui lâché
sanitaires que nous vivons n'est qu'un
avatar de la crise écologique qui est
bien plus globale
donc il faut changer cette façon de voir
il faut passer d'un modèle de la
concurrence à un modèle de la
coopération concerne nous n'y arriverons
pas